hi i'm masahiro sacra injectibles must
process welcome to game line say Ubuntu
started a new school for myself I want
people I want fans of all different
types of games to play this game enjoy
it I really feel that if the characters
that we have in the game are appealing
that they will stand out and that
hopefully people will whether they're
Nintendo fans are not Nintendo fans or
the characters themselves are from
intentions we'll go back and maybe look
at some of the the series of the games
of these characters came from and maybe
go back and investigate them I believe
that every character has its own appeal
its own unique personality that reeks of
the game and I think that if I look at
it and that light I find that each
character is endearing of its own way
those especially and right after the the
completion of smash brothers melee eyes
I have to speak with mr. Kojima and we
talked about including snake in my
impossible in this universe and I just
thought at that point like well a non
Nintendo character in this sort of game
would bring a different feel to the game
would appeal to different audience and I
just thought it was something that would
be really interesting and I immediately
came up with you know the image of snake
within this living this match brother
see my sodium you know cool constant 109
company announced snake as a playable
character after 33 we immediately on our
super smash brothers dojo website put up
a survey for fans and visitors to the
site to choose a character that they
would be most happy to see introduced
into the series and even if you include
all of the Nintendo characters saw me
close by at large the character that
received the most votes so that's that's
really where it came about we we know
that's one of the main impetus for us
bringing Sonic it's like evident you
know I'm not only interested in jobs as
be making director but rather I would do
but wear different hats depending on
what was required of me if I thought the
project was something that was going to
make the game in history more
interesting and more fun for everyone
quad you think you'll indicate this
thank you I guess I just liked first of
all apologize but the delay I'm very
sorry that it's late that being said
it's it's here and you will have in your
hands shortly and I really hope that you
will all take the time to play the game
and I really hope you enjoy it thank you